Welcome to now you see this video of a
train was first screen to a group of
people in France in January of 18,
96.
Legend has it that the viewers of the
film were so overwhelmed by what looked
like a train coming right at them that
many hid under their seats or ran to the
back of the room in fear of getting hit.
The truth of the story is debated,
but what's certain is that seeing a
video for the first time have a train
coming towards you would probably leave
you pretty shocked and amazed.
So the question is even more than a
century later,
can we be just as moved by film or are
we desensitized because we know that
things on screen aren't actually
happening.
I want to explore the war film because
we're films have such great potential to
shock and amaze us through their sheer
scope and powerful subject matter.
How can film to portray war and what
techniques do filmmakers used to picked
war and the soldiers that fight them can
film portray war realistically.
Let's take a look at two types of war
films,
probe war and Anti War French filmmaker
friends,
swatch Hifu is often attributed with
saying there's no such thing as an
antiwar film.
While Steven Spielberg said in an
interview with Newsweek magazine,
of course every movie good or bad is an
antiwar movie,
so who's right.
I want to argue that while neither of
these statements is correct,
they do give insight into the nature of
film,
but before arguing,
if a film is pro or anti war,
we have to define pro and anti war.
A definition like antiwar portrays war
in a bad light and pro war portrays
we're in a good light is somewhat of an
oversimplification.
A lot of war films show a combination of
positive and negative aspects of war.
They were expendable.
For example,
shows Japanese airplanes blowing up a US
pt boat and killing a soldier.
Look at this shot of John Wayne
collapsing at the side of the boat way
down by his combat boots,
the camera following him to the ground.
This scene reflects wars,
cruel,
dangerous,
and dead.
But if we look at the movie as a whole,
it's definitely a pro war propaganda
film.
Look at this shot up,
General Macarthur commander of the army,
he towers over the camera,
speaks little and is treated by the
soldiers as a celebrity please.
He's looked at as a hero and savior up
for the United States and this and along
with lots of pro war sentiment in the
film shows that they were expendable as
much more pro war than Antigua.
I think a better definition for a pro
war film would be a film that shows the
benefits of war outweighing the cost and
an antiwar film shows the cost of war
outweighing the benefits.
A modern example of a probe war film is
American sniper.
Clint Eastwood makes the claim that the
film is antiwar and it definitely has a
lot of aspects of an antiwar film.
The film shows that word isn't always
black and white and can cause serious
emotional trauma.
But what makes it pro war is that Chris
Kyle believes he did the right thing.
I'll just protect them.
My Gosh,
they were trying to kill our soldiers.
And,
uh,
I'm willing to meet my creator and as
for every shot that I took,
the film is pro war because it conveys
that despite all the trauma of war war,
I'm blessed with the gift of aggression.
Overpowering need to protect the flock,
rare breed live to confront the wolf.
They were the sheepdog.
The benefits of war outweigh the costs
and worry is unnecessary evil against
those who caused terror.
It's with films like American sniper
where I think Spielberg is wrong in his
statement about war.
Films or films normally don't make out
war as something to look forward to,
but they can certainly make wore out as
necessary.
Pro War films use heroes and an idea of
the greater good to convey the message
that war is necessary.
It's antiwar film,
showcase the brutality and cruelty of
war to portray combat negatively.
To get a look at how filmmakers you send
them a tography to have an antiwar film
show the horrors and realities of
combat.
One has to look no further than the DJ
scene in saving private Ryan.
The transition from the old man in the
opening scene to the beaches of Normandy
is done with a jarring smash cut.
We don't fade.
We don't zoom in.
It's a fast and abrupt transition.
It gives the effect of being forced into
the scene without adequate preparation.
The shot of the endless rows of anti
landing barriers on the beach looks
eerily similar to the rows of tombstones
in the graveyard.
We just saw in the earlier scene a
foreshadowing of what's to come.
We get several closeups of soldiers and
they certainly aren't the typical war
heroes.
The first image of our hero is his hand
shaking,
a sign of fear.
Compare that to the grand introduction
of John Wayne on a squadron of pt boats
that are basically showing off to the
camera or even American sniper where
Chris Kyle first gets shown with this
huge,
powerful sniper rifle.
The Omaha beach scene shows a war fought
by the terrified not by the heroic or
masculine.
The killing on the beach is best
described as pure chaos.
The camera shake point of view shots and
minimal movement blur all work together
to pull the viewer onto the battlefield
alongside the other soldiers.
With all these effects,
this scene definitely conveys that the
costs of war outweighed the benefits.
A great way for a film to Portray Warren
in negative way is to make war scenes as
realistic as possible by putting us in
the real world.
We feel the terror and get a sense that
war may not be worth all the turmoil it
causes.
Waltz with Bashir is another great
example of pulling us into the action
and showing how work could have such
devastating effects.
The movies and animation war,
film and the resulting effect is that
were removed from the reality and the
film because it's animated and doesn't
look realistic.
Then in the last minute or so,
the film quickly cuts to actual footage
of the aftermath of the massacres in
Lebanon.
The result is heart wrenching.
It jars us from the spectacle of the
animation into the harshness of reality.
We see widows crying dead bodies and
it's all thrown at us with no
preparation for the transition from
cartoons to reality.
The effect is extremely powerful and we
realized that what we were originally
seeing only an animated characters is in
fact exactly the reality of war and that
reality is horrific suffering.
If that's not an antiwar film,
then I don't know what it is.
I do see where the food is coming from
when he says there's no such thing as an
antiwar film.
He's saying that film by nature
contained spectacle.
Since we're not actually on the
battlefield and our safe in our movie
theater seats,
we don't completely feel exactly like
the soldiers do because we're removed
from the reality.
This removal makes it difficult to
construct a film that truly leaves
people,
discussed it at war because we're safe
from it.
We can enjoy watching the destruction of
film in the theater.
Famous director,
Samuel Fuller,
upon watching the very antiwar,
full metal jacket stated that it was
just another goddamn recruiting film.
Even when films try to criticize war,
sometimes they can still give the effect
of making more glamorous cinema as an
art form is limited because no matter
how John we are to the movie,
there's always that barrier from
reality.
A train on screen doesn't frighten us
like it would in real life,
so maybe we are a little desensitized by
the screen.
We aren't shocked like the viewers of
the train were back in 18,
96.
Some may say that's a limitation to
film,
but to others it's a challenge.
It's a challenge all filmmakers have to
tackle.
They have to surprise and astonish us
even when we're used to watching film
and maybe not every blockbuster these
days can blow you away,
but every once in a while if you're
lucky,
you get to see a film that hits you like
a free
train.
Thanks for watching.